アプサラ・ウパー・アヴィチッタ
無因 不善 未熟心がありましたね
それは結果として得られる
そこでこちらでは大心といって八種類の善心が説明しました
そちらの結果として八種類の未熟心と八種類の無因
これパーリ語でしか言えないんだから
八種類のアヘーとかクサラ・ウパー・アヴィチッタっていうのありますね
そこは生まれちゃうんですね
では十五種類 十六種類の結果が得られる
こうもうチャートいろいろ勝手に書いてこなきゃわかりにくいかもしれませんだけど
まあ面倒くさくてやらないしね
チャート書くまでのところじゃないんです
僕にとっては もっと難しいところありますからね
まあまた思い出してください
十八種類の心が説明しました
その十八種類の心の中で三つは置いておきます
十五は善と不善の結果なんですね
そこで不善結果は七つありました
この不善結果の七つの心が十二種類の不善心の結果なんです
悪いことをすると心が十二種類が生まれる
その結果報いが味わう時は七種類の心が生まれるということ
で 不善の世界は終わりと
善の世界はいいことをする場合は八種類の心でいいことをする
その報いを受ける場合は十六種類の心が生まれる
そうそう その十六種類生まれるんだけど
システムはこういうシステムなんですね
例えば人が喜怒喜びがあって
智慧があって 右用の心で何かをいいカルマをしましたと
それで結果としても もしかすると喜怒で智慧があって右用の心が生まれるかもしれません
いわゆる生まれた心 それにプラスあの八
九つが生まれる 十六全部生まれるわけじゃないんです
いわゆる自分の生まれ作った心は一つしかないんだからね
その一つをこの八から選ぶんです
まあ一旦書いて説明します
もう向こうで日本語で書いた方が早いんです
大心の 地蔵を 下で書いてこないと説明できなくなっちゃいます
まあお風呂入ったっきりです
[咳]で このようにこの八種類の善心
大心があります で 人がいいことをすると
そのどちらかの心で行動する
この八種類の 喜 愚 痴 相
応 有業 無行 有行か 喜 愚
痴 不相 応 無行か 有行か
あるいは捨 愚 痴 相 応 無行か
有行か まあそれ まあうんうんと
その八種類の心で の中で
何か一つの心で行動する
その時その時 今我々にはこの八の中でどんな心で生まれるも可能性ですよ
カルマとしては そこで結果の場合は同じ心に我々イジュクシンと読むんですね
で この中で 例えば喜 愚
痴 相 応 無行という心で人がいいことをしましたと
そこでその人はもう死んでからこのいい生まれ変わる
生まれ変わるためには新しいショーキシンが生まれなくちゃいけないんですね
新しい心が生まれなくちゃいけないんです
その新しい心は もしかすると喜
愚 痴 相 応 無行のイジュクシンかもしれません
いわゆるこの同じ心のイジュクシンかもしれません
あるいは番目かもしれません
三番目かもしれません
八番目かもしれません
どっちでも構いません
なぜならば このリストの中で一番目は結構力強い心なエネルギー強いんです
なので喜んでやってるし
智慧もあるし また無行でもあるし
行動的だから 本当はカルマの結果にはこれはもう関係ないんですけど
有業無行はね まあないんだけど
まあ一応そういうふうに言いましょう
で 喜んでやるよりは なんとなくもう別に喜びなく
あの普通の心でやる場合は
エネルギーはなんか少ないように感じちゃうんでしょ
すごく喜んでやる場合はエネルギーは強いし
ああそう じゃあやりましょうという感じでやっちゃうと
そんなにエネルギーはないんですね
精神的に ですから 一番目は力強いんだと
二番目は まあちょっとより力は少ないんだと
八番目はもっと力が少ないと思っても構いません
ということは もし人がいいことをする
その場合は喜 愚 痴 相 応と有行であったならば
その人は生まれ変わる時は同じ喜
愚 痴 相 応 有行の心で生まれるか
三番目で生まれるか 四番目で五番目
六番目 八番目で生まれるか
どっちでも構いません
可能なんです これはなんか山手線にね
まあ大体この最高な山手幾らでしたっけ
二三十 四十かわかりませんだけど
それぐらいの値段で切符買えば
一つ目の駅で降りたってもいいし
三番目で降りたってもいいし
六番目で降りたってもいいんです
山手線全部もうまあ一番高額の切符買ったならば
でも百三十 百円か百五十円ぐらいしか買ってなかったならば
二番目の駅で一番目の駅で降りるか
二番目の駅で降りるかと
せいぜいもしかすると三番目
この距離に関係ありますけど
三番の駅で降りるかと
それ以上行っちゃったらもうお金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
そんなもんなんですね
ですから そういう風な感じで
もうエネルギーの働きなんですね
ですから もし人が大変喜んでカルマをする
でもチッ不相応 知恵はなかったと
それで愚業であったと
その場合はカルマとして同じくチッ不相応
愚業で生まれるかもしれませんし
五 六 七 八で生まれる可能性もあります
というふうにまず理解してください
また ここの落とし穴があるんです
死んで生まれ変わるっていうのは
死んで生まれ変わるって今言ってますけど
八十年かかって人生終わって生まれ変わるのか
それとも瞬間的に死んで生まれ変わるのか
人生はもう全部終わってから
一旦生まれたら その心はもうしょうがないのです
そこでこの落とし穴っていうのは
この このリストなんですね
問題は このリストのこの貴具足と四つと
捨具の四つでしょ？その順番はあまり正しくないんです
正しい順番というのは
智相応の四つと 智不相応の四つなんです
正しい順番 だからこの心の差が見ると
知恵があるかないかってのは
この大変な大胆なことなんです
喜んでるかいないかってのは
別にどんな大胆なことじゃないんです
この喜びを元にして順番書いてますけど
それはあんまりどうでもいいんです
一番大事なのは知恵があるかないかってことなんですから
順番はこの順番なんです
貴具智相応無行・有行と二つと
捨具智相応無行・有行二つと
それは上の四つと 下の四つは
貴具智不相応無行・無行と
捨具智不相応無行・無行なんです
その順番でカルマの結果を計算しなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ先生 一 二 五 六と
三 四 七 八っていう風に
ですから この順番でいけばね
まあこれは一で えーと
まあこれはまた二で これは三で
これは四で こんな感じになっちゃうんです
あまりに精密すぎて なんか精密しちゃうと習慣ありますね
このフォーマルの場合
一応そういう順番なんです
この順番じゃないんです
これもうアビダルのテキストにこういう順番であるんだから
私に文句言ったっても私は知りません
正しい順番はこれ 知恵がある心は四つは上
知恵がない心の方が下と
それで一番目の心がどうせ一番だからね
で カルマをしたら一番の同じ心が結果として生まれる可能性もあるし
下の七つのいくつか生まれる可能性もあるし
ということは 知恵のない心で知恵使わないでいいことをした
その結果として知恵のある人の心で生まれるっていうことは
ちょっと不可 ちょっとどうかなと
でも知恵で行動して 結果として知恵はないチッ不相応の心で生まれることは可能なんです
ものすごい当たり前の原理だと思いますけどね
難しいことはないんです
ですから これで仏教で言うのは
とにかくいいことをする場合は
ちゃんと知恵を使いなさいと
ちゃんと理解して やりなさいと
それぐらいのことで 別にもう頭の働きだから
よく理解してて もういいことをするべきですよとか何とかとかね
まあ理解してやるのはとても簡単だから
そうすると結果は一応いいんじゃないかなと
それぐらいのことで 有行・無行はあまり関係ないんです
ほとんど関係ない 結果と
有業であろうと無業であると
俺は大したことがない
それから性格的に明るい人であるか普通の人ではそれまた関係ないしね
どうでもいいんです 人間として一番必要なのはこの智慧があるかないかということなんですね
と言っても この八つの心での一つで生まれ変わったら
結構頑張れば智慧が生まれるんです
ですから 悟れるかないかといったら
もう悟れる可能性があるんです
その四つの八つの中で
地相応の人々はまあほど確率は高いんです
地不相応の人々は まあ二
三倍他の人より頑張れば悟れる可能性はあるんです
決してないわけじゃないんです
アビダンマではなんか全くないような感じに持っていこうと頑張ってますけど
そうじゃないんです 悟れるんです
ですから そこで能力のことを言っちゃうんです
いわゆる地不相応ですけど
強弱があるんだと 地不相応の弱の心だったら悟れないんだと
強だったら悟れるんですよと
まあそこはどうでもいいんだけど
一応まあもしかするとひと何倍も修行しなくちゃいけないかもしれません
でも悟れる可能性はあるんです
人間に生まれたならば
そこをどこで判断しますかというと
簡単なことなんです 我々の基本が
基本というか 体の基本
え 体のまあ体の構造なんですね
目やら耳やらね 大体ノーマルで機能しているならば
もうカルマはいいんです
生まれたカルマは 目はちゃんと行動している
耳は行動している いわゆる普通の元気な人間で
子供で生まれたならば
修行すれば悟れるんです
いわゆるこの新しい この生まれを作った心が体作っちゃうんですね
そこで作った体がすごいガタガタで障害ばっかりだったら
生まれた心はもうあまり力がないんだとわかるでしょう
ですから そんなに難しくない
理解するのはね 大体この仏教ではありがたく思えと
修行する前に私は手がすごく働くわ
足がすごく丈夫ですと
体が調子がいいんだと
目がよく見えるんだと
耳が聞けるんだと いわゆる五根がちゃんと付いているんだと
それだけではなくて 頭がよく働いてる
動くんだと ということは
私は立派なカルマで恵まれて生まれたんだと
それだったらもうちゃんと修行して悟らなくちゃいけないんだと
もう悟れるんだという風に自分をちょっと自信をつけるなさいと自分に
ということなんです ですから
まあ例えば体の機能がね
いろいろ衰えていると
基本的な心の問題なんですね
基本的な心 心は大工さんだから
大工さんはちょっと能力がない
能力ない人の 作る結果はどうせ欠陥でしょ
ですから 自分に悟れる
悟れる 何て言いますか
能力あるかないかと 知りたければ何のことなく簡単なんです
自分の体とかね 見たら別に問題ないでしょ
ですから ほとんどの人間には可能なんです
障害とかいろんな持って生まれるのはものすごい数少ないでしょ
人類の中で こんなちょっとわずかしかいないんだから
ですから そういう人々を置いておいたっても
人類のは修行すれば悟れるんです
それがオープンであって科学的なものですからね
教えは 大体そういうところで計算する
悟れるかないかと その中でちと相応だったら結構頑張らないとダメなんですね
そこまで人間の我々の生き方を見たっても
わずかな努力で成功する人がいて
すごい努力して成功する人はいますよ
例えば入学試験の東大にすぐもう何のことなく
すぐ一回の試験で入る人もいて
まあ 年間浪人やって入る人もいるんですね
で 私はある人のことを知っていたんだけども
歳になってまあ回目かな
司法試験を受けているんです
でもいつでも ダメなんですね
とにかく弁護士になりたくても
まあ今度は回目 回目に頑張りますよとかね
ですから もしかするとその人はもう回ぐらいね
回ぐらいでも まあそこまで生きているか分かりませんだけど
で 頑張ったところで弁護士になるかもしれません
そんな弁護士は役に立ちそうにないですけどね
その話 でもできないということは
またね とにかく知恵がないんだから
分かりやすく言えば で
一回では合格しないだけで
あの あの あの 今あの事務所にいるあの人
何でしたっけ あの奥さん
真理教の 弁護士が青山ですか
青山さん若い人でしょ？学生の時はちゃんと弁護士になっていたんだから
それはもう知恵 地相だから
もう何の楽々に まだ学生のことも学生時代も終わってないのに
ちゃんとした弁護士 で
そういう人も世の中で見たらもうよくありますね
ですから 仏教っていうのはやっぱりだから諦めるなということなんですね
特に瞑想の場合はね まあ諦めずにもう頑張った方がいいんです
あまり気長くして頑張っちゃダメなんですね
今日はやりますという気持ちでやらなくちゃいけない
まあまあほどほど まあそのうち悟るだろうという感じではダメなんです
今日はやりますとやって
終わったらもう今日はダメでした
じゃあ本当にやりますということでいいんです
諦めないことだけ でもやる時はもう今日はやるぞという気持ちでやらなくちゃいけない
そうでないとね ちゃんと中道的な立場を守れませんだけれどね
守れませんだから あまり気長く考えちゃったら
絶対効果が出てこないんですね
で できないわけはないんです
悟れないわけは全くありません
全くない 生まれつきもう障害だったら
まあちょっと許してあげてもいいんです
優しくしてあげてもいいんです
そうでないと絶対優しくしてはいけないんです
このつの心でいい行為をしたら
それなりのふさわしい心で生まれ変われる
それで生まれ変われる時も
やっぱり確実に番目の心
心には番目の成熟心ということではないしね
そこら辺もこのちょっとした
この 何て言うか その場合ばらつきというんですかね
ちょっとしたこの差があるんです
ちょっと別のことも聞きたいんですけど
地相という言葉ですね
最初僕は知恵と思ったんですけど
青山大の知識というのもあったし
それからその前に理解というようなものも説明してるんですけど
それはどういう風に言ったらいいんでしょうかね
地相を実際に言って 知識という形で持って理解するという風に表現するのか
あるいは知恵として出てくるのかということなんですけど
地相ですから どういうふうに取るでしょうね
仏教的に理解すればいいでしょう
その場合は 言葉の遊びではないんだからね
地はああだこうだ 知識はああだこうだとかね
大体この何て言いますか
ニャーナさんと言ったという言葉ですから
それなりに適当に理解すればいいんです
そんなにも そんなに問題ないんです
それはもうすごい一般的な理解でいいんです
ということはですね それがカルマになって
その構文がカルマになってきましたよね
ということは ですから
例えばね いいことをその地と言われます
さっきのその少しずれての説明が来てますから
青山を見てね あの人は地があったという知識があったというふうな理解を思ったんですか？それとも勉強しなきゃいけないという知恵が
知恵があったから勉強したのかというふうに説明したのか
要するに地による説明がわからないんですよ
地が地が必要で一番大事だと言っている
だから私にとっては別にそれはどっちでもいいんだけど
青山さんというその若い若者
若者にとっては 生まれつきは地相で生まれたことだけは確実なんです
能力というふうに見えたりするんですけど
どっちでもいいんですよ
自分的には 何かに掴めない限りは大丈夫なんです
別に これ感情で自分の頭を混乱しているだけでしょうね
僕の方で青山という人が大
なんていうか悪人として見てほしいでしょ
そんな人は判断できませんし
その人は大変幸福に生まれたことは確かであるし
一人息子ですごい豊かな家族で何も問題なく
ということはすっごい抜群の
カルマなんですね それ証拠には
小さい時からもう天才で
日本で歴史上初めて一番年下で弁護士になったし
ですから ある点では歴史的な人物なんですね
その人は後から何か悪いことをしたということと
生まれたカルマとは関係ないんだから
それはわかるんですけど
それではですね 今青山は地不相なのですか
いいえ  違いますよね  今も地相なんです
地相なんですけど じゃあ
じゃあちょっとそれはまたおかしいですよ
ということは 知と知 それは瞬間瞬間にも入れ替わるでしょうと思うんですけど
心の奥のところですね
それから最終的に死ぬ時に
さっき佐々木も言ったみたいに死ぬ時にそれで決定すると
その時であると言ってましたね
地がこの地がというような形でなっているのは
どちらをどういうふうに選んだらどうなるんですか？知なるのか
不知なるのか 瞬間瞬間に心は変化するはずですから
どちらかのような形でやっているはずなんですよね
で 知でと青山自身がもうずっと知で生まれたら
ずっと知でじゃあ死ぬんですかね
うん  そうなんですか じゃあいい心にする必要ないんじゃないですか
もう生まれた瞬間から知であれば
そのカルマというのは
だから今喋ってるのはカルマの結果だからね
うん 天皇陛下で生まれた人は天皇陛下で死ぬんです
次にどこに生まれ変わるかっていうのはまた別な話で
例えば旅館さんがいたでしょ
日本で あれも天皇のね
息子であって それ辞めたでしょ
辞めて命を守るため 辞めて出家してあっちこっちふざけて遊んだりしていたんだけど
立派な人なんです まあそんなもう例はどうでもいいんだけど
あの自分今世でもらった能力は消えるわけないでしょ
能力の問題 それ能力で生かしてください
例えば今例に出した青山さんがすごい能力持って生まれたでしょ
その人はどんな悪いことをしたっても
能力まで消えたわけじゃないでしょ
今刑務所でもいろいろ頑張ってるかもしれませんし
そうでしょ 例えば犯罪を起こす人々がお医者さんとかね
刑務所に行っちゃったら
またそこでも頑張ってますから
医者の知識は消えるわけじゃないんだから
医者が例えば殺人したんだと
それで法律上は免許は取り消し
あの医者でしたよね なんとかっていう林さんというね
それ正真正銘の医者でしょ
そこで人殺しちゃったんだから
もう医者ではありませんだけど
だからってその人に薬治療できませんか？できるでしょ
心臓外科なんとかでしたから
今でもやればできるんです
だから能力は消えません
うん 資格がないだけ そこで鈴木さん
もしかするとこれは混乱しているかもしれません
カルマとカルマの結果という 2つあるんです
カルマっていうのはいつでもできるんです
私は今やることはカルマで
僕はその愚痴相っていうのは
そこでカルマのものを作ってしまうと思って
だからこれは今 イジュクシンのことを言ってるんです
イジュクシンは結果と言ってましたね
結果ですから報いのことです
だから報いの場合はまあどうしようもないんですよ
例えば人が 犯罪者がいるんだと
その犯罪者がもうそれは別の話で
このどこかでお金を投資していたんだと
会社に そこでその犯罪は裁判で決められて刑務所に入れちゃったと
そこで自分が株を買ってた会社がどんどんどんどん成長しちゃって
すごい自分が株が高くなっちゃったと
それで株を売ったところで大金入っちゃうんだと
大金が入ることは誰にも断ることできないでしょ
あんた刑務所いるんだから冗談じゃないんだと
それはまたその話は冗談じゃないんです
ですから 結果はしょうがないんです
過去のカルマの結果だから
そこで青山さんの例に戻りましょう
青山さんは痴相で生まれたんだと
痴相で生まれてよく勉強できて
よく生活していて それから生まれた時は何がやるかということは
その人のカルマで人を殺すこともできるし
もうむちゃくちゃいいことをすることもできるし
それはカルマであって結果じゃないんです
だからカルマとイジュクシンと 2つなんです
イジュクシンはもうどうしようもない
それは手に施しようもない
カルマの心はもう努力できますよ
すごいいい頭で生まれなくても
ずっとバカで生活することもできるし
痴不相応身っていうのは
だってこれ上身のはずなのに
なんでこうなるんですか
上身ですよね これね やっとのことで痴不相応身になってしまうんですか
そこら辺のところ  ですから
この常識 だから痴不相応だからといって不浄身になるわけじゃないし
ただ智慧がない智慧といったってそこら辺ちょっと曖昧ですけど
貪瞋痴がありますね 布団不尽智ありますね
そこで でまあちょっと問題ありますけど
とにかくこの不貪と不痴という心性が働いていて
不貪と不瞋 痴は働いてない
いわゆるいいことをする場合は
どんないいことにも基本は欲はないこと
怒ってないことということを基本なんです
明るい心っていうのは基本なんです
それプラスアルファで智慧あるかないかと
欲がなくて怒りがなくて明るくすることはだいたい普通できるんですね
智慧はプラスアルファなんです
なんですか 智慧ってなっちゃうから
そこで  大丈夫 だから言葉に引っかかっちゃうんですよね
智慧あるかないか そのままで行ってしまう
そんなに言葉に引っかからなくてもいいでしょう
ただの言葉だから ただの言葉でしょう
それはもう大乗仏教の世界では言葉に引っかかっちゃって
まあどうでもいいことよね
もう般若分析するわ 空は分析するわ
もうあれは子供たちが砂遊びと同じですから
何のこともないんだから
問題は感覚であって 自分がどう感じるかと
例えばこちらの知というのはそんな簡単に定義できないでしょうに
例えば人は人間はいいことをするべきですよと思うことも知恵であって
仏教の行動的な理解も知であるんです
だから知にも知の差っていうのはすごいあるんです
我々どこまでいるかで
皆様もいいことをする場合は
今まで仏教を勉強しているんだから
それは知想なのです そこで私も知想を持ってますけど
同じじゃないんです 私はもう徹底的に原文で勉強しちゃったんだから
また私の知能レベルは違うかもしれません
数学できると言えば これは小学生にもできるし
中学生にもできるし 大学教授にもできるし
それは数学の知識があると
でも数学の知識のレベルが様々なんですね
ですから この知想と言ったってもいろいろあることはあるんで
そんなことを考えちゃっても頭狂っちゃうだけだから置いとくんです
ただ知想だけで十分だと
だからニャーナさんと言ったニャーナがあるかないかと
そこでもっとわからないと言うならば
定義あるんです ニャーナっていうのは
カルマの働きを理解していること
いいことをしたらいい結果が出るんであって
悪いことしたら悪いことが出るんだと
それぐらいの理解はニャーナなんです
それぐらい理解あれば知想なんです
だからそれだけ止まるわけじゃない
悟ることも知想だから
でもこの心では悟れませんだけど
それは俗世間な心ですからね
ですから 例えば生まれつき人々は知想であろうとも
その人はどんな生き方をするかっていうのは生まれたからの責任であって
例えば生まれた心が知想だとそこでずっと人生も知想で
死ぬ時も知想でまた生まれ変わる
知想だったら人は一歩先で全然上下もないでしょう
何が何も何もそうじゃないんだから
今王様で生まれた人は死んじゃったら犬に生まれ変わる可能性ありますから
それはどんな生活するかっていうことで
次の次次の生を決めちゃうし
一旦王様で生まれた人は 1年経ったところで犬になって
3年目にまた王になると
そこはないんです 王子で生まれた人は王子で王になって
それで他の誰かに国を盗られなかったならば王で死んじゃう
でも死んでからは王としてどんな生活していたんですかということによって
犬になるか人間になるかという
これまた別の話 カルマの結果はもうどうしようもないんです
さっきのそのまたさっき生まれた時にもうカルマの
結果としてその心が同じ
死ぬ時も地相で死ぬって言ったんですけど
これやっぱりそこで変化するものであれば
その言葉 違う言葉とかあるんですか？言葉
はい  いやあの 生まれた時地相で呼ばれて
死ぬ時も地相で死ぬということをさっき言ったんですけど
今心は当然変化すると言いましたですね
当然変化するのは当たり前と思ってるんですけどね
だから死ぬ時は地相じゃなくて水相でいくんじゃないかと
それまた違う言葉で表現するんですか
いや そこはこれからもなんか
違う言葉がない  変化する
どうして  例えば生まれることに心には正気心という
死ぬ心には あ 生まれ結焼心と言うんです
死ぬ心には ちょちちった
えっ ちったなんだ ちょちちったなんだ
パーリ語で言えばね えっ
最後の心なんて言いますか
死心 結焼心と死心と言うんです
名前は違いますけど 結焼心イコール死心なんです
まあいいや それは後でも全部出てくるもんですから
そういう部分を  そういうのは後で全部説明するんだから
地相ってずっと続くんですよね
いろんな情心とか  まあこう考えてください
例えばこのいじく心というのは結果だから
例えば我々はボールを持って上に投げたんだと
手から離したならば もうどうしようもないでしょ
適当な高さに行って落ちるんですね
それには何も文句言ったって何の意味もないんです
ですから 手からボールを離すことは結焼心で生まれ始めたんだと
そこで手から出したエネルギーによって上へ行って
それからある時間かけて落ちると
それは寿命であって それはまあどうしようもないんです
そこで あの  ボールの場合はそれだけのことですけど
例えばその投げたボールが他のものにぶつかって物を壊したりあったこと
それとまた違う結果なんですけども
そこら辺混乱しちゃったらもう全くわからなくなっちゃうんであって
やっぱ混乱しないようにしなくちゃいけないんですね
僕は一生懸命混乱しないように
この まあゆっくりと順番で考えてやってますから
先に飛んで考えちゃったらもうどうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
とにかく大乗仏教の概念とはもう全く合わないので
合うならば私が言います
ここら辺合いますよ  あの
大乗仏教的に言うとですね
ですからその地相か地不相としても
そのいじる心という いじると言うお釈迦から通るんですけど
異なる心って異なってしまいます
変化してしまうという概念があるんですよね
いじく心ですね いじく心ですからね
ですから 異なる心というね
ものがあるんですよ  だから感じにこだわる必要ないでしょうに
結果  結果だけど 今の結果と次の結果が少し違うわけ
一分だから というね それなら先生の説明と合うんです
今は2ですと言ってて
それで死んだ時に その時の一生の結果によって
それが2になった5になった6になった
そう変わったら  それだけ自分だというふうに言うでしょ
説明するでしょ 先生さっきその地相だから地相で考えてったから
一生の間は変わらない
性格とかもうみたいなもんだから
一生の間はずっと2の組で生まれ変わるということになります
それが死んで その人のその一生の間の方によって
それで亡くなった時に
生まれ変わる時に 次のまだ5に生まれ変わったら8
いやいや 生まれ変わらないから一生じゃ同じだよ
その君 地相でもう生まれ変わらない
永遠に地相そうなっちゃう
いや 一生 一生 一生じゃない
だから変化する  いじくっていうのは変化することです
じゃあその時に1から7変化するということですよ
ということが  例えばね
例えば人がこの心でいいことをしましたと
その人には選択あるんです
この8から1つと あの無因心の8つと 8 8
ですか 8ですね それ8とこちらの1つを選んでくださいと
こちらから1つだけ 9
つはできます ですから
あの いいカルマをしたならば 9
つの心で喜びを感じられます
その9つの場合は 8種類はもう基本的で決まってるんです
それは無因いじく心なんですね
無因心いじく心なんです
こちらから1つ選ぶんです
例えばこちらの一番選んだら
もう 7つまでどれでも大丈夫なんですね
それ選んでくださいとは人には選べませんよ
その時の状況によって自分が決めますから
決めるんじゃなくて 自然にそうなるんだからね
それはわからない 誰にでも
ですから とにかくわかりやすく言えば
1番目の善心でことをいいことをした人にとっては
この8の中